um i i wonder if we might start with
this the case of
uh the missing uh princess latifah what
is the
british government's position on this
well look you can only watch the footage
that you've just shown now and uh
see that there's very distressing uh
pictures
a very difficult case um and i think it
is concerning
uh we always raise human rights issues
with all of our partners including the
uae
um there's no particular british locus
in this case but we are concerned by
this and
i noticed that then we've seen that the
united nations high commissioner
on human rights will be following up uh
on what we've seen
and we'll be watching and monitoring
that very closely indeed
from what you're saying it certainly
feels like we would not be in a position
as yet at least uh to talk about
sanctions to talk about
perhaps inviting the ambassador in for a
chat
we always raise these issues with all of
our partners across the police including
in the middle east where we have to have
some of these difficult conversations
i've always raised human rights issues i
always do with foreign ministers with
the
ambassadors and i think the right thing
given what the united nations has said
is to follow very closely
we're obviously always supportive of the
united nations high commissioner
on human rights and i think that's the
proper course right now to follow those
developments quite closely
of course we do have a relatively close
relationship with the united arab
emirates there's trade of course there
are security concerns
one understands that you know this issue
is not going to immediately change the
the nature of our relationship but one
has to say you know given the fact you
know we had a uk court
ruling back in 2019 that not just uh
uh princess uh that they're not just
that princess
not just the princess has been abducted
her sister as well sheikha latif
sheikha samsa was kidnapped on british
soil
i mean on the basis that at least one
of his children looks to have been
kidnapped here don't we have more of a
responsibility to get involved
well certainly in terms of the private
law claim that went through their uk
courts obviously uh
we not only respect but would expect
compliance with
uh any and everything that that it's
decided and to the extent we can control
that of course
and any criminal matters rightly for the
police and they should investigate them
without fear or favor would you that mr
rabb support
seeing some kind of proof of life of
princess latifah
from uae i think given what we've just
seen i think
people would just that a human never
want to see that she's uh alive and well
of course i think that's a natural
instinct and we would certainly welcome
that
um i wonder if we might move on to to
the announcement that you're making
today and of course uh the uk and its
role on the security council
you know it it is there are
opportunities for us to push
a number of agendas tell us just a
little bit though about the
ceasefires and conflict zones i mean
certainly we need to get the world
vaccinated for the world to get back to
normal and that
clearly will have to involve areas in
which there's conflict how would that
work though
so the uk is stepping up to the plate
we've got the presidency of the un
security council and you're right
there's two things we're particularly
focused on
the first is trying to get a covid
vaccine ceasefire because with the new
vaccines which is a big
change since last year when this
resolution was uh
pushed by the french with our support we
got an opportunity to get to some of the
most
vulnerable around the world and one of
the things i've seen as foreign
secretary is the compound
impact abroad in the most vulnerable
countries for the most vulnerable people
of three things famine conflict and
kovic
and so if we can uh through the un
security council which is the
international
uh community's top body for uh passing
rules and
and making uh statements around
international law and what's required
if we can just see a window of
opportunity to reach
those really vulnerable people in those
uh terribly afflicted countries
i think we'll be doing a lot of good and
that's what global britain's all about
and that's what we're going to be trying
to secure on top of the
support for the equitable distribution
of vaccines which were already leading
the way
uh in terms of the uh kovacs amc
mechanism we've provided 500 million
pounds
that will produce uh a billion doses
again for some of the most vulnerable
people around the world there's the two
things we want out of this debate
uh later on today which i'll be chairing
indeed um
of course we we are ahead of much of the
rest of the world not just in
in getting the vaccination into people
but in terms of the purchasing
of the vaccine we had a considerable
degree of foresight
uh when it came it came to hedging our
bets as such as it was in
in terms of who we ordered from we've
clearly got on order at very least
more vaccine than than we could ever use
at what point
do we start to think seriously about
about redistributing that have
we heard from the vaccines minister at
the weekend potentially not until
every adult in the uk has had a vaccine
so first of all um we're already trying
to support those
most vulnerable countries the lower
middle income countries around the world
and the right way that the international
community can respond and which we're
leading on
is the cove kovacs amc mechanism because
you put money in
it secures the doses the kovacs amc
arrangement has uh supply chains with
the different vaccine suppliers that's
the first thing it's the most important
thing it is going to be the clearing
call that i make
in the un security council later today
it's true as well
um if we've got excess supply in due
course when we know
not just the amount of vaccines we need
but the timing we would
then want to think again whether there's
an additional router support that we
might be able to provide
we're not there yet but we're already
stepping up to the plate in the way i
described
by putting money in and using our
convenient power to get other countries
to match it
that's the way we'll support the most
vulnerable countries the most vulnerable
people around the world
and show that we need a global solution
to a global pandemic
it is slightly away from your brief but
i'm sure it's something that
you know about the the letters that will
be being sent out to around about just
less than two million people
telling them that they they need to
shield it it all seems the product of
this that this algorithm that is driving
at least part of our pandemic response
can you just explain exactly how we have
why we find ourselves in this situation
what the metrics that this algorithm has
identified
are and and how soon we might think we
can be in contact with these two million
people
so obviously we want to make sure our
response to the pandemic is updated as
we learn
more about the virus and and also about
the vaccines
oxford and it's called the cucovid
uh program has through data that it has
modeled
found that there is a particular
additional vulnerability
in relation to certain compound factors
so it's things like
age sex uh body mass index all put
together
and it's 1.7 million who we think um uh
are at greater risk
about half of those will already have
had
uh the vaccine or wrong calls to the
vaccine under the current rollout
so there'll be another uh around again
half of that number who were contacting
to say first of all you're now a
priority for the vaccine we want to make
sure they get it as soon as possible
and secondly we're urging them to advise
them to safeguard
until the end of march with all of the
support on things like statutory sick
pay um
guaranteed delivery of supermarket and
medicines that will come with that
i think it's the right thing the
responsible thing to do to make sure
when we learn about people who are more
vulnerable to the
virus that we do everything we can to
provide them extra support
that's the approach and we'll be
notifying them immediately as soon as
possible
yeah i i'm sure that they will be great
for when when they're
when they're contact but just in terms
of how we come out
of the of this phase of of covid19
that there seems to be a very strong
indication that what of course you have
always maintained
testing testing and tracing is at the
heart of of getting us out of this but
it feels like we are about to embark
upon
a program of mass testing around the
country to try and keep on top of this
as the vaccine
continues to be rolled out can you just
speak a little about that
we learned um previously in places like
liverpool and other areas uh in the
north
the value particularly when you've got a
spike of testing done
at scale and at pace particularly with
the new lateral flow testing
but as we roll out the vaccine and as we
start to think and the pm will set out
the road map forward
on monday so on the 22nd of february and
he'll set up the details
and as we get the feedback the data from
the impact of the vaccine
the the two or three things that are
going to be really important uh if we're
to uh ease out of lockdown
uh safely and responsibly uh yes of
course the vaccine
and the therapeutics which aren't much
talked about but the drugs that help
uh take some of the fertilities that the
fatalities out of
um those that contract the virus but
also this lateral flow testing being
able to do it at scale
at uh pace so that when you do have
upticks
of the virus we can come down on it like
a ton of bricks and make sure
and it's only one part of the strategic
jigsaw if you like but make sure we can
come down on it like a ton of bricks
um so i said there's a range of
measures but testing and rapid lateral
flow testing
is a key part of that um and minister
again
slightly away from your brief but but
i'm sure it's something that you you
will have a view on
we keep keep hearing in terms of the
quarantine hotel scheme
we keep hearing that passengers from red
list countries
are on the plane once they arrive in the
airport all the way in fact
to the border checks are being allowed
to mingle with passengers from
from non-red less countries what are we
going to do to sort that out
well we've got a series of measures in
place already you have to have a covered
test to get on
um a flight in relation to those coming
from the redless countries obviously if
they're
they're brits we've got to get them
safely back home and what we've devised
is the most
uh safe and effective mechanism that we
can we know that the numbers of people
traveling have come right down and we
have the
hotels and the hotel capacity um to make
sure that they can
then quarantine at home for 10 days
sorry not at home at
a a government commissioned hotel uh in
safer conditions it's only
one of the lines of defense and
obviously we we're struggling with this
balance
as we have right the way through and
we're striking the right balance
between uh robust measures to safeguard
the vaccine from coming in but also
looking after british
nationals who who we need to uh to cater
for and take care of we think we've got
the right balance i think the system is
working
uh reasonably well but but as i said
it's only one of the safeguards only one
of the lines of defense
to prevent either variations from the
vaccine or people
unwittingly carrying the vaccine coming
back into the uk at this critical moment